due to popular demand many of you have
been asking my pad I want to get a top
10 documentary list what are the top 10
documentaries I got to watch as an
entrepreneur I'm gonna give it today in
today's episode if we had Buffett and
gates here and we resurrected jobs and
said recommend a book to you you still
wouldn't read a book these documentaries
are specifically to you so for you guys
that only watch documentaries click on
the subscribe button here and give us a
sub and join the notification squad so
let me get right into it
number 10 documentaries I'll sleep when
I'm dead see when I watch his
documentary I watch it a night before I
was sitting down with Steve Aoki to kind
of talk to him about what his life is
all about how did it go from being a
regular guy in Orange County to all of
us are making twenty eight million
dollars you're DJing how do you make
twenty eight million dollars you're
DJing and you're on a Forbes list and
when you listen to his story of his life
you will realize exactly why he became
he became his father went on one of
these hot-air balloon rides and went
from Japan to us that was a Guinness
Book of World Record for like 30 years
and his father was wrestling champion
and Steve Aoki's the son and he has to
overcome the shadow dragon top this guy
hears my dad I gotta top and he does so
when you see the dynamics about the role
his mother played his father played it's
an incredible documentary to watch now
number nine
seeing all red this is a story of Gloria
Allred she has settled lawsuits nearly a
quarter of a billion dollars in her
career so when you watch this
documentary a lot of people say oh you
know she's all about public humiliation
she's a feminist she pins men against
went woman all this other stuff I've
seen feminists that don't even know what
feminism means and I know feminists that
truly believe in what they believe in
when her and I sat down in her office
everybody was uncomfortable this is
gonna come out here soon but one of the
things I respect about her story is the
fact that this woman is an absolute true
believer it'll make you think about true
believers in a whole different way
number eight this is the story of Enron
the smartest guys in the room and he
fast thought was the former CFO for
Enron and him and I have sat down we've
spoken we've had some very very good
conversations together he's changed his
life dramatically after what happened
before to what it is today you hear a
time when everybody was doing what Enron
was doing they got caught now listen
they weren't doing the right thing but
everybody was doing so if everybody is
doing you're into makes you kind of like
well they're doing a worse
we are what's wrong if I do what's wrong
if we do it boom and you get caught and
this is when capitalism gets a black guy
this is when you hear certain news
channels MSNBC and CNN say capitalists
they're filled with greed and all this
other stuff in these types of scenarios
they're right hopefully when you watch
it you'll say to yourself I am involved
in certain things in my business right
now that's great I highly recommend for
you to get out of it because all it
takes is one time one time for something
to happen and your business is gone and
you have to go back and rebuild your
reputation your business and it's just
not something you want to go through
number seven Evod Couture this is the
story of a host back in the days in the
80s 90s Morton Downey jr. who is the son
of Morton Downey senior and what
happened to him how he came up his
father used to be this major singer
everybody knew about they had a house
right by the water and the Kennedys had
her behind them so he hung out with the
Kennedys and everybody knew and they
respected the dad and this kid is trying
to outshine his dad he would sit there
one time they brought a magazine in with
his father before he is getting
interviewed and he throws this trashes
his magazine all over the place
flips out temper he just wanted an out
shadow his father's I don't want to be
in this guy's shadow and then he gets
the opportunity becomes the biggest
thing on television and what happened
for him to go from here
passing Oprah pass and Phil down hill
passing everybody and what caused the
fall when you study the fall you'll sit
there and say wow I never thought about
it this way again because sometimes when
you get caught up about a lot of
attention you're willing to do anything
and everything to get more attention
because you always want to top the
attention and sometimes you can cross
the line and that's when a big follows
around the corner EVOC you towards the
great documentary you gotta watch you
can actually find it on Netflix number 6
becoming Slaton this is the story of
Slaton ibrahimovic which is a very very
famous soccer player thing right now
he's playing for LA Galaxy this guy's
made a few hundred million dollars
playing soccer and he just recently gave
up a ninety million dollar contract to
play in China for two years for three
million dollar contract to play in LA
for two years which is insanity but he
took it the reason why this documentary
is very important i watch this
documentary on my sister's house because
my nephew sean is a ridiculous soccer
player whom i believe in i think this
kid can do some special things with this
life Somnath is Sean if you're watching
this body your uncle loves you and
there's a part that's very
he is going with this agent to sign his
first contract and he is 1617 years old
this agents in its mid-40s and his agent
is nervous he looks at his agent very
calm assess Hey Hey look at me settle
down calm down calm down
act like you've been here before a 16 17
year old kid is telling a 45 year old
something like this and the agent looks
and says oh I'm sorry yes yes you're
right we have been here before and then
they're going to negotiate here's a
person that's 45 that's this agent is
given advice by 1617 or relax we belong
here
stop acting like this is such a big deal
why is this so important for the younger
people to watch this it's because some
of you think you have to be 40 45 50
years old to go out there make these big
deals and big negotiation deals here's a
16 17 year old kids who know how much
time and effort here putting in a tray
to become as good as he is right now
which gave them the confidence to tell a
45 year old listen relax we got this
just go to the negotiation that we need
to do here to get the deal that we know
we deserve and he when I got it done
very very important documentary for the
younger teenage entrepreneurs to watch
but it's on a list of a documentary
that's must watch phenomenal document or
I would have put it higher but I put out
the ranking that it is right now number
5 the 85 Bears so we rented out the
biggest private castle in America 32
bedrooms I rented the entire place that
this is in New York and we had a meeting
and imagine it's 9 o'clock at night it
is snowing it is a white outside snow
all over the place we're sitting there
in this room lights off I'm standing up
the entire time lights come on at the
end everyone's in tears everyone's
crying I said tell me what you're
thinking right now and they went through
the process you see the story there is a
story about a coach named Mike Ditka who
was a phenomenal Chicago bear player he
used to be the first tight and
hall-of-famer great guy as a player that
ends up becoming a coach yet the
credibility in the locker room was a by
a guy named Buddy Ryan whom the
defensive guy would've ran through a
wall for this guy named Buddy Ryan and
it was Mike Singletary and all these
other guys that can you know quarterback
who was going through concussion tests
that he was doing all these things and
you seen the dynamics of leadership how
the Bears broadened Ditka and said buddy
Ryan you're gonna report to Ditka and
Buddy runs like wait a minute I'm
supposed to be the head coach and it
didn't happen many times when you're
running a business
you're running a team ownership or
somebody's gonna make the wrong call on
who needs to run the whole thing and you
still gotta figure out a way to make
your work and you still gotta figure out
a way to say listen I know you think I'm
in this position no problem I'm gonna go
above and beyond and show you my
leadership level that I have an
accompany needs to be higher and
hopefully to get notice so you know what
happened at the end of the day they won
the Super Bowl and it's a very emotional
Super Bowl in how they win it it's the
only time in the history of sports and
football this is the first time where
they carried the coach and the defensive
coordinator buddy Ryan this has never
happened because the players are trying
to say you were just as much as of a
coach to us as Ditka was and bitkha
yours later agree when he talks about
the story it's just very emotional I got
the chills just thinking about it
because I remember when we were in Oheka
Castle and going through this whole
process phenomenal documentary to watch
with your team you want to have a team
movie this is the one to do it with and
number four four days in October which
is the story of the 2004 Red Sox that
are down three to nothing to the New
York Yankees and they make a comeback
this has never happened before the
entire country was rooting for the Red
Sox because they hadn't won a
championship for a while
since they traded what Babe Ruth the
whole thing that they did all these guys
are cursed because it's the curse of the
Bambino I cannot believe they're going
through this now we got some insider
information about what happened with
Kevin Millar Kevin Millar the third
baseman who was not the top-five best
player on that team at that time Manny
Ramirez had come off the Cleveland
Indians he was playing with Joey Belle
those guys at that time they had Pedro
Martinez which was killing it Curt
Schilling and he had the blood on his
leg they had Papa who was just leaving
Ortiz was coming from Minnesota that all
these other guys that Johnny got all
these guys right but everyone had given
up cuz the Yankees you're just gonna
come down it had the stacked team
they're gonna get it Kevin Millar third
baseman not the top five best player on
the team morale the story here you don't
have to be the best guy in the company
to rally everybody sometimes it's just a
guy that comes in and changes a spirit
before the game this doesn't make in the
documentary this is just insider
information due to proper investigation
that we have here with the company Kevin
Millar pulls all the players I said
listen if we're gonna lose we're gonna
lose that's to shot a tequila
everybody because a shot at a killer
before the game and they go out and he
starts going and talking to the news
guys the Journal says hey you look like
you already picking Yankees don't pick
the Yankees I'm telling you don't pick
the Yankees we're gonna get it don't
pick they picked the Red Sox and
telling everybody and they so loose
Yankees come out like this you know how
Yankees always look so proper you know
they're gonna kill him why skip them are
so excited and in the game start then
it's three two what if everybody on the
SP is going Kristen in three three and
then they went for three em the Yankees
locker room they're sitting there like
what the hell just happened today this
documentary is such a great documentary
for you to watch with your team
especially if you're behind in your
numbers and you try to make up the
numbers and you're trying to inspire
some people in your company to be a
Kevin Millar pump and iron and this is
the story of arnold schwarzenegger
listen if you're a bodybuilder you
exercise you've probably watched this
before it's gotta be one of the best
documentaries of all time it tells the
story of Arnold before he became Arnold
and you will see glimpses of how this
man who ends up becoming a governor
state of California he really learned
how to debate when he was playing
against these other competitors against
Ferrigno he would go and sit down and
talk to his parents and how he would
throw off his competitors and the jokes
and how loose it was and a lot of people
think well this guy's just a muscle guy
and he's just a big guy he's not that
smart he was brilliant men women
everybody watch it you'll be entertained
and you'll learn a lot about business
and life as well
number two super mensch is the story of
chef Gordon business is all about
marketing you got to figure out a way
how to market how to tell the story chef
Gordon maybe a person not a lot of
people know the regular day-to-day world
but let me tell you something everybody
in Hollywood wished chef Gordon was one
of their friends or representing him
because this is a guy that moves you
know he wants to be a firefighter I
think or cop or something like that he
moves to LA stays at this apartment
world he's still at Jimmy Hendricks
everybody staying there I saw by the
pool one day he starts smoking weed with
all these other guys they hook up
together they start hanging out together
and said I think you need to do this I
think you need to do that and he had
people artists that was a trouble
chicken in the audience just some random
guerilla marketing creative ideas that
nobody had ever done in Hollywood and
entertainment and he did it he pushed
the envelope by the way when you see how
he talks when you see how he's wired
very calm very easy very chill and when
he does parties in his house and Hawaii
you know who shows up on his birthday
party names of names in Hollywood that
oh my gosh what's he doing here at a
friend of mine Byron who they want to a
party of his at his house in Hawaii he's
fat Oprah Winfrey was that everybody was
at this guy's house at the party
chef Gordon documentary called Superman
she made it at number two and last but
not least Sena this is the story of
Ayrton Senna many of you who know me you
know how much I love Ayrton Senna to the
point where my youngest daughter's first
name is Senna spelled the same exact way
Sen nati rheton Senna was a guy who
brought so much pride and love to his
country of Brazil when Brazil was going
through the phase where this guy was
winning championships after
championships after championing Prost
beating all these guys he was Cup he was
at that time the Michael Jordan of
Formula One Prix Michael Schumacher
right Michael Schumacher looked up to
this guy he came and changed the entire
game one time he was racing watch this
how efficient this guy was he's going
around a turn and he hits the tires on
the side the wall he comes out and he
tells to all the people that are the
officials he says that wall was moved he
says it wasn't move I'm telling you that
wall was moved six inches we're telling
you it wasn't roof he says let's go
outside they go outside with the
officials officials look at he says you
were right the wall was moved six inches
how can you tell six inches apart when
you're driving that was Ayrton Senna
when he died 12 million kids in Brazil
went to school because of art and
Senna's non profit his sister ran it 12
million kids in Brazil they went to
school because of what arctan said I did
with his legacy my challenge to
everybody with this documentaries watch
how this man wanted to find out what the
best version of himself could look like
that's all he was after he wanted to
find that what can I look like if I give
my best to this game and he end up
finding out about it whatever you're
doing whatever industry you choose you
gotta ask yourself what can happen if I
give my best in this industry what is
truly my capacity what is truly my upset
if I give everything I got what is my
ceiling you're always gonna end up
breaking through the ceiling if you end
up giving your best so that's why I made
a number one obviously it's got a
special place in my heart all the
Brazilian community Brazilian value
tenders you know how we have that
emotional connection on Instagram and
snapchat when we go back and forth I
love Center for many different reasons
but Senna's documentaries number one for
mindsets that he had unlike that I think
can help any entrepreneur out out there
so these are the top ten documentaries
if you haven't seen any one of them some
of these you can get on Netflix some of
them you can't if you want to order any
of the documentaries we got a link below
that can take you straight to the
documentaries to buy and watch what I
want to hear from you if you've watched
any of the
send me a tweet at Patrick vid David and
if you haven't each time you finish one
of these documentaries send me a tweet
and let me know what you got out of the
documentaries after watching it thanks
for watching and if you haven't
subscribed to this channel yet again
click on the subscribe button I told you
I'm not doing books this time I'm doing
documentaries hopefully we gain your
subscription this time take everyone
bye-bye
[Music]